well that didn't take long
no one sets the tone more than president
of United States and the tone that he
sets is one of division often one of
hatred this has now become a struggle
about good versus evil and the president
of the United States is evil this man
was the flames of his hatred were fanned
by a president who kept talking about
this caravan of refugees as if they were
terrorists so as they blame Trump's
words for violence do they realize
they're excusing the violent acts
themselves while offering a case for
leniency for the actual perps if the
actions of evildoers are out of their
own control and nothing else could have
led to the violence then how can you
even begin to punish these creeps it's
wrong being wild for both the bomber and
the shooter president Trump mr. law and
order pushes the death penalty there is
no ambiguity there
he places the blame firmly on the
dirtbags and like most Republicans seeks
out the stiffest penalty literally the
stiffest this contradicts the media who
see Trump as a hateful ringleader who
sympathizes with such cretins speaking
of those suspects they were total losers
failures in life who placed their rage
on others and anyone with an opinion
could provide a trigger because words
can't influence it's why there's
advertising but that's a scary path to
take especially for Hollywood rap stars
and video game makers or even people
paid to speak carefully and thoughtfully
the President of the United States is
racist even Albert Einstein may have
ended up in a Nazi concentration camp
with Donald Trump's viewpoint on
immigration if you vote for Trump then
you the voter you not Donald Trump or
standing at the BART border like Nazis
though you hear you hear so you want
hate you spend two years calling a guy
Hitler a racist a traitor and insane
then you blame him for violence because
the nicknames no lectures from you kids
but even more it's a sight word
as the cause eliminates the suspects
entire history and the slew of variables
that brought him to commit his crimes it
makes no sense legally or morally but
politically I guess that's another story
after all why let a crisis go to waste
except that you'll make another one far
worse all right Lisa didn't waste any
time I mean I guess we saw it coming
that they would they would pin the blame
on on Trump well absolutely we've been
paying any attention to the media over
since President Trump even announced but
look there's obviously a complete double
standard in the media we know this when
something happens to Republicans the
media and the left say that we need to
have civility on both sides when
something happens and is directed at
Democrats it is purely Republican and
president Trump's fault but it's also
just intellectually dishonest because if
you look at the mail bombing suspect
this guy has a rap sheet going back to
1991 he made a bombing a terrorist
threat in 2002 and then if you look at
the synagogue shooting this guy hated
President Trump because he didn't think
he was an anti-semite so if you actually
look at the facts it doesn't drive the
narrative that the media is driving but
the only reason they do it is because
the media the midterms are around the
corner and they want to hurt President
Trump one can I play Sarah Sanders
responding to a reporter about the this
whole mess go why you see out there when
you say he's trying to unite the country
why is he out there the very very first
thing that the President did was
condemned the attacks both in Pittsburgh
and in the pipe bombs the very first
thing the media did was blame the
president and make him responsible for
these ridiculous acts
you can't start putting the
responsibility of individuals on anybody
but the individual who carries out the
crime he's delivered on the promises
he's made and if anything I think it is
sad and divisive the way that every
single thing that comes out of the media
90% of what comes out of the medians
mouth is negative about this president
so one by question to you is I think you
can hold two opinions that Trump's
discourse you will say is the bicep and
I could say that that because he's
pugnacious so you know it's divisive but
that also map mass killers are
responsible for their actions alone
don't you think that tying that together
and
putting it on him is politically
opportunistic politically opera title ed
I led you with the answer no but I want
to engage you seriously because I think
this is such a serious topic but I think
that you're right there two thoughts and
they can be held simultaneously right in
other words that in fact you have to
hold the culprit responsible for his
individual action it's also the case
that the president engages in divisive
speech and that's the problem here I
think that he's up the ante in terms of
divisive speech so part of it and what I
heard in your monologue and from Lisa is
blame the press that the press is not
fair to him and he's gone back now to
the press is the enemy of the people but
I think this goes from my perspective
beyond that because his rhetoric is so
intense that I think it has you know
sort of created an atmosphere of more
kind of dissonance and vitriol than
we're accustomed to to my mind you know
what we've seen the last week or so it
makes me wonder is this America how did
we get to this point and then over the
weekend you know just you know put me
aside because I just worry that you say
oh well that's why I am clear is the
press again but here 35,000 people Greg
saying the president will not be welcome
in Pittsburgh unless he denounces white
nationalism and here's words from this
group this is a Jewish group been the
Ark they say for the past three years
your words your policies have emboldened
a growing white nationalist movement you
yourself call the murderer evil but
yesterday's violence is the direct
culmination of your influence okay I
don't know much about that group but I
do know I think we have tape from CNN
when they were actually asking this
specific rabbi from that synagogue about
whether Trump was welcome there I think
we have that I'm talking slow enough so
you can set it up that work President
Trump has talked about coming to
Pittsburgh and coming to your synagogue
in the aftermath of this do you want him
to come
throughout the President of the United
States is always welcome I'm a citizen
he's my president
he's certainly welcome there you go kill
me and what are your thoughts on what if
you care to respond to Juan about his
feelings no way those groups I don't
know any of those groups but it just it
sounds like Democratic talking points
sounds like something Tom Steyer said on
CNN on Sunday whoo I didn't ever say
talked besides the ads that he bought
and the money he made I was just stunned
if you asked me when this happened first
the bombers discovered - the shooting on
the synagogue I thought maybe by Sunday
on a Sunday show some pundit looking to
get a Network contract would go ahead
and say I think the president's to blame
I did not know the same night the same
day within an hour they said haha look
at what you see where the president does
and it works to his detriment as he
watched everybody talk about all this
and it came had him seething as if we
were sitting outside the glass listening
to the five talk about us for him he's
listened to he's outraged so where's the
president do exactly what he did his
entire life at the Trump Organization as
a candidate and as a president
I'm going to go tweet out I'm gonna
speak out of that you guys are blaming
me for this you're making it worse the
way you treat me
has my 60 million who voted for me and
maybe more seething ready to go now that
has nothing to do with that lunatic in
Florida and that nut that nutcase in
Pittsburgh but I do think that there's
there's a sense out there that Trump is
trumping his supporters have been
categorized like as white nationalist
because they voted for him and they're
tired of it and he's speaking for them I
don't think it's about voting for him I
think that if you look back at some of
the actions not only the bomber and then
the shooter but I mean go back to
Charlottesville proud boys and all this
kind of stuff that there's a growing
white nationalist rage in this country
and people are like whoa do you realize
though that the president Trump's
daughter is Jewish his son-in-law is
Jewish his grandchildren are Jewish I
actually think President Trump has a
special spot in his heart for the Jewish
community you see that in his actions as
well moving the embassy to Jerusalem
being the first sitting president to
visit the Western Wall so I think that
it's often not talked about in this
national dialogue is the fact that it
was so close to the president thanks
Lisa that really bugged me about
Charlotte so everybody put it in terms
of the Confederate statues black white
but you know they
guys with tiki torches and automatic
weapons standing outside a synagogue so
the Jewish people had to exit through
the back door and those same guys said
oh what a shame that mr. Trump would
allow his beautiful daughter to marry a
Jew they were universally condemned good
let me get Dana in here the media oddly
enough didn't mind louis louis
farrakhan's tweets earlier this week
where he said what he compared jews to
termites but will not go there you had
Andrew McCarthy on your show and I made
a really important point that back in
the 70s United States was a much smaller
country I don't know how many by
millions but had many many more of these
kinds of attacks so we in fact it was
the New York Times yesterday had an
amazing report it was like it was on our
website like really well done I'd point
anyone to it was actually talking about
1968 because it was the 50th anniversary
and we're looking at this now that in
1968 just how divisive things were I do
think we all have to keep a binder
keeping a redline between speech and
violence is really important that's how
America was founded I also feel like the
president could figure out a way to read
the room a little better and I'm at me
in like the country right like take take
a couple minutes tap the brakes just a
little bit because for better or worse
people tend to look up to leaders and
they want to feel better about the
moment and if the moment becomes about
him and the media treatment of him then
we're just right back down into it and
then somebody's gonna have to step
forward and do something could I just
add one last thing no we got to go and
that is the the issue of radicalization
of people we've we talked about this a
lot during the war on terror how does it
happen right well you have hopeless
people purposeless people people who are
ignorant and then they find purpose in
something that they find somewhere now
is online so if you have radical
Islamists that how do they find it and
there's something that tip there's
always a there's something I don't as I
think it's speech but there is a
culmination of it and if you look at
this guy's background Boyer's background
he certainly had it right he turned evil
and vile into violence and what we
should be talking about what the
president said is I'll do everything in
my power to stop it from happening again
okay so what do you what is in your
power to do and that's some pretty
uncomfortable conversations about
privacy and the ability to we can
prosecute
very well what we don't seem to be able
to do as well is to prevent right and
you think about what what prevented
institutionalization was there for
unstable individuals we don't have that
anymore there are a lot of there are a
lot of unsavory unstable people with we
don't know where to put him and this
other guy the bomber everybody he was
out he was hiding in plain sight
apparently five minutes before he left
he posted I can't take this anymore
because he couldn't take any more
refugees coming in and you it was
supported by the Jewish community so if
it was five minutes before it was from
five minutes from posting to shooting
yeah as composed as Barack Obama is this
charismatic great speech I get it but if
he was blamed for the South Carolina
shooting for the Gabby Giffords shooting
she was blamed for Sandy Hook
he might fly off the handle too you're
kidding me what you got there is a
contrast between someone who talked
about hope and change and someone who
presses the film and then opens the door
to suggestion proven fried wings are
somehow responsible for the terrible a
it's not the language we got to go